anyway have a great weekend and let me
Daisy Italy get up pack stuff cos it's
all over
listen we had a rough couple of months
lucky Katrina's cousin Maria the other
one while Rico Houston [ __ ] Florida
listen has been tough
up to now the earthquake in Mexico
you know the White House whoever the
[ __ ] is going on but it don't matter
they want to shoot it's time for us to
[ __ ] this shoot [ __ ] they want to
get down and dirty
don't forget who the [ __ ] we are you
understand me
we're the baddest [ __ ] out
there you send the message to that
[ __ ] North Korean he's gonna be
sniffing my dick and suckin my [ __ ]
that's the focus with other North Korean
like a year is gonna be an island is
gonna glow in the dark you know life is
what Americans got suckers who the [ __ ]
you think you're dealing with stop with
the gun control they're selling more
guns than ever the last three days stop
with the [ __ ] whining stop with the
Russians on Facebook I don't give a [ __ ]
worry about yourself keep the eyes open
and get the [ __ ] on snapchat and [ __ ]
Twitter sucker stay black